I mean clearly you dating no I'm not
dating right now but I love life besides
you sorry sorry we're on a date
but um I just I'm really just enjoying
my life and my time with my baby and
family and I don't want to do why not I
don't know I I'm so fine not dating
where I know like GTO if you think about
it in the future do you know what kind
of guy you would want down the road what
you mean I don't and Scott I don't what
I've never really put that much pressure
on dating I'm just you know whoever you
are in a room with that you connect with
and there's chemistry then that's you
should date but I'm just not even in
that headspace we got to ask you oh we
did see part one another little show you
guys are on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians we saw some of the finale
what is it like for you to watch that
back to relive that really tough time
that you went through
I personally don't watch it back because
I just I already know what happens and
it it's just I think a little too toxic
for me to keep reliving stuff like that
so I stay off social I don't I didn't
watch it and it's just a part of our job
that we kind of have to do so we can't
just pick and choose what we want to
show that's not fair and so that's just
what it is but Jordan never once has
Jordan said I'm sorry I'm sorry Ashley
either side it's just not cool for me
fashion s is there anybody I don't think
there needs to be negativity on anywhere
I think it's just a story that's being
told but anybody picking aside or you
know condemning any human I think this
is a part of life I'm not saying it
wasn't yeah you know everyone has their
truth and their story and so you just go
with go with it
the right to speak their truth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]